the search for alien life in the
universe is one of the most intriguing
quests of our time from UFOs to little
green aliens to the possibility of life
in the underground aquifers of Mars
there's no end to speculation as to what
form this life could take and how it
could have developed there's even a raft
of videos on the internet speculating
that aliens must have visited ancient
civilizations on Earth
because otherwise how else could the
Mayans have built their incredible
temples
spoiler there is no evidence at all for
this and frankly if I was a Mayan stone
worker from 250 A.D I would find it
deeply insulting but a more interesting
Theory and one which has more
credibility is that of panspermia
that life exists throughout the Universe
and can be transported through space
from one location to another although
it's certainly not proven a team of
prominent scientists from MIT and
Harvard have been working on the theory
that some form of life was actually
delivered to Mars in this way is that
possible here's what we know life is
incredibly adaptable just look at the
way our own species has managed to
thrive across the globe and
microorganisms such as Archaea and
bacteria over the course of millions of
years of evolution have been able to
modify themselves in order to adapt to a
vast range of conditions this means that
today there are microbes that can
survive on a variety of diets sulfur
ammonia
the metal manganese and in the presence
or absence of oxygen some even survive
in the most extreme conditions Earth has
to offer pyrococcus furiosis don't you
love that name thrives in hydrothermal
vents on the sea floor its optimal
growing temperature is 100 degrees
Celsius whereas the Antarctic
cyclobacter frigidicola prefers things
decidedly chillier you can also find
these extremophiles hanging out in Hot
acid or surviving desiccation in salt
crusted deserts and some of these
microbes can even deal with several
extremes at once denococcus radio
Durance can be found in both hot springs
and Antarctic soil survive desiccation
and is one of the most radiation
resistant organisms we know so these
extremophiles are probably the most
oven-ready organisms to survive and
potentially colonize the Hostile
environments on other planets and moons
as long as there's liquid water at least
some of the time
but how would these tiny microbes even
make the journey to these other places
well the easiest way is to Hitch your
ride with us as we explore our solar
system and beyond tercycoccus phonesis
is a bacterium discovered in NASA
spacecraft cleaning facilities could we
have already accidentally introduced
bacteria from Earth to the Moon and Mars
another possible way for these microbes
to get around the solar system is by
hitchhiking on meteoroids when these
crash on a planet rocks and debris are
shot into space generating more
meteoroids so far
313 Martian meteorites have been found
on Earth and an earth rock was also
found on the moon therefore we know
there has been interplanetary transfer
of rocks still how could these
hitchhikers survive in space Once In
Space the cold and lack of oxygen are
easily dealt with by our Hardy voyages
and even regular bacteria can enter a
state of dormancy under extreme
conditions creating thick walled
internal safe rooms for their DNA called
spores heat cold acid drought and UV
resistant packets of bacterial DNA
voyaging through space another big
problem is that space is brimming with
ionizing radiation that rips DNA to
shreds not a problem for dinococcus
clumps of this little fellow have
survived three years of exposure to
outer space others have survived up to
six years in Spore form yet another
problem is time space is Big so
traveling anywhere takes a long time
that said in 2020 Japanese scientists
revived bacteria that have laid dormant
at the bottom of the ocean for a hundred
million years
so perhaps the extraordinary distances
aren't such a problem for these tiny
space Travelers the final step is
surviving the crash landing onto your
new home
and bacteria have been shown to be able
to do just that
as long as they are in deep fractures in
the cosmic Rock so it's entirely
possible that microbial life has already
traveled to somewhere like Mars
conditions there were remarkably similar
to Earth 3.8 billion years ago could
these extremophile microbes have already
colonized the underground aquifers of
Mars if they're already there
have they adapted to their new
environment or maybe life on Earth
actually originated on Mars and then
traveled over to our planet they may not
be little green aliens or intelligent
life as we understand it but their very
possibility that life could have
transferred across the solar system and
beyond is deeply intriguing and as the
James T Webb Telescope begins its search
for telltale signs of distant life on
other planets could we perhaps find out
that life is far more inevitable than we
once thought
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
hit the Subscribe button and click the
Bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video